around the globe venomous creatures are
on the rise some weigh over 400 pounds
while others are barely visible wondrous
and elegant
they have no bones no heart and no brain
but that doesn't stop a few from
inflicting excruciating pain and even
killing in minutes there'll be 60 odd
tentacles and you only need somewhere to
see about five to six feet worth of
tentacles across your body
and that's enough to cause death within
maybe 120 maybe 180 seconds the
jellyfish and now we're about to get a
lot more familiar with these fascinating
floaters species around the world are
blooming out of control and infesting
our oceans Australia Indonesia Japan and
the United States they can pose a threat
to humans and sea life alike
and it's up to scientists to learn more
about their ever-growing number to do it
they need to infiltrate their world in
the dark depths of the sea what I'm
really interested in is trying to work
out where and what they do for a living
so what I'm trying to do is able to
predict when they turn up and when they
disappear if we can do that that makes
the beaches a heck of a lot safer but
the surf won't be safe if jellyfish keep
reproducing at such an alarming rate and
humans might have something to do with
it
I think there's little doubt that the
impact of humans worldwide has has major
consequences on the change of jellyfish
populations worldwide you pollute the
water with some stormwater runoff from a
big city and you stress out all those
polyps potentially all of those polyps
will go into jellyfish making mode and a
bloom will result in blooms can wreak
havoc near the shore and out at sea in
either case and encounter with the wrong
jellyfish and it's lethal venom
injecting tentacles can mean near
instantaneous death all the blood cells
that are exposed to this venom will
immediately swell up and explode
the venom destroys blood cells causing
severe blistering and possibly cardiac
arrest with jellyfish numbers soaring
throughout the world humans in some
areas should be wary and until we learn
more about jellyfish their worldwide
invasion may continue